I thank the members of the United States
Senate Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell for his leadership and steady
resolve
I thank Judiciary Committee chairman
chuck Grassley for his wisdom and
fairness and I give special gratitude to
senators Rob Portman Susan Collins Joe
Manchin Jon Kyl and Lindsey Graham they
are credit to the country in the Senate
I'll be forever grateful to each of them
and to all the senators who carefully
considered my nomination that was the
new Associate Justice of the US Supreme
Court Brett Kavanaugh thanking members
of the Senate including my next guest
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
senator Graham I said this to you last
week and I'll say it again tonight I
don't think this would have happened
without you the moment where it was just
organic for you was extraordinarily
powerful in as much as it was righteous
indignation at that moment and the other
thing I'd like to say I don't think it
would have happened I watched the speech
of Susan Collins and I said this Friday
night on this show I think was the best
Senate speech I've ever seen yes
methodically laying out the case with no
influence outside from anybody under
enormous pressure and I've heard every
horrible thing said about this woman and
I'm thinking where is their sense of
decency and dignity if you lay out an
intelligent case but you just happen to
disagree well it's about outcomes for
our friends on the left there's nothing
they won't do to maintain power there's
nothing they won't do to take it back
when they lose it Susan Collins
represented the best in the country she
thought about what she did she explained
what she did and she made a reasoned
decision the people on the other side
were going to destroy Cavanaugh we let
him to the extent that my intervention
helped a good man who was being
railroaded and humiliated I'm pleased
and to president Trump thank you for
sticking by Bret - Bret thank you for
having the courage to stay in there when
a lot of people who quit I'm very
grateful to both Brett Kavanaugh and
President
what I see now in people a level of
energy and enthusiasm and just raw we're
not going to put up with this that I
think is ignite s around the country I
don't know the impact that will have on
the country in 29 days but considering
that we see every two four years and
every confirmation these tactics we
can't reward this behavior because we'll
just get a lot more of it I think that's
what Susan was understanding is that if
she legitimized this process God helped
the next person to be nominated for the
Supreme Court if we legitimize this
process the rule of law gave away to the
mob rule the Hirano standard is horrific
what was insulting is the way that the
senator from Hawaii took everything we
hold near and by the way she said she
said men should shut up and sit down
shut up senator and sit down I only
thing that girls really do yeah thank
you I appreciate it
thank you very much and it probably
right at the time but the people of
South Carolina gave me my voice not the
senator from Hawaii and I and I chose to
use it in a fashion that I thought I
said I think what a lot of people were
thinking and Senator Collins gave the
best explanation why a reasonable person
would vote for judge Kavanaugh and we're
gonna take this to the ballot box 29
days from now you got a decision to make
America do you want to live in the world
of senator Hirono where you're guilty
and to proven innocent because you're
Republican you don't have a presumption
of innocence or do you want to live in
the Susan Collins world where you'll
actually be heard listened to and
evaluated you know senator I've been in
this game I'm now starting my 23rd year
at Fox tonight and 30 years on radio
what kind of been pretty lucky
I've been waiting any minute for it all
to come crashing down like everyone else
but I will say this to go you're good
when you when you look at the progress
we made it as a country I haven't heard
one idea from the other side that will
improve the lives of the people that
matter most people in South Carolina and
the people and the rest of the
country that are seeing the economy boom
or security get beef and up in ways we
never imagined just two short years ago
well there's two issues in this election
everything else has kind of gone by the
wayside are you okay with what they did
to Cavanaugh is this the America you
want to pass on to your children we want
women to be heard and respected dr. Ford
was heard she was respectfully treated
but we also want a constitutional
process that protects all of us not just
Republicans not Democrats but all of us
and here's the other question on the
ballot what do you have to lose well I
tell you what if we lose you got a lot
to lose you're gonna have a smaller
military you gonna have a bigger
government you're gonna have less money
in your pocket if they win you're gonna
have a bunch of people who are organized
around the idea of hating Trump so I
would say there's a lot to lose if you
turn over power to my Democratic
colleagues there's a lot to lose in this
election and I hope you understand that
all right Senator Lindsey Graham I don't
know if this would have happened without
you
you did your your constituency in South
Carolina you served them well you serve
the country well we are forever in your
gratitude for that thank you sir